hey all attended catch here and I've
officially graduated from University I
awoke in the Tippie analytics alumni
shirt and for this week we're actually
not gonna look at the tight squeeze day
data set I believe that data set is a
volleyball data set however I don't only
know a lot about volleyball and I think
we kind of cool to build off of our
previous data set that we created which
was the UFC data set so I think it'd be
cool to make it dashboard specifically
in our using our shining one of the main
questions I'll you probably ask is well
why would I use our to make a dash for
when I can use like tableau or power bi
that's a pretty good question because to
be honest if you're just doing basic
reporting visualizations and your data
set is static or in a database it's
probably easier and probably better for
the user to just make it in tableau
because easier to give to people and off
all stuff also the filter functions are
much easier to implement but one good
thing about our shiny though is you get
more you get more data science tools
right so you can add trendline you can
really tweak those plots and you can
also do kind of add whatever you want
it's it's kind of open source so there's
a lot of cool package that you can add
on to our shiny instead of using base
our shiny we're actually gonna use the
shiny dashboard package and what's great
with a shiny dashboard package is
because is it adds a lot of um it kind
of gives us a template to start off of
to really make a great looking dashboard
just out of the box okay so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna load up
where's my where's the thing I have a
are shiny app right now I'll load it up
you just do file new file and then shiny
web app you do that I have it because I
actually added in a we add I added in
the data sets were rushing to use okay
so I'm just gonna erase these comments
um it always comes with these comments
and we don't really need it to be honest
oh let's see what else we need
need that don't need that don't need
that okay
so this is the main skeleton of the are
shiny dashboard however what we're gonna
do is when it load in the typers we're
gonna load in the Ehlo package and we're
gonna load in shiny dashboard okay and
then we're also gonna load in our
original Ehlo data frame ego-t SS csv
and we're also gonna load in this other
one called
the e lo csv and if we actually look at
it let's see if what's hopefully it'll
work yeah so our D F dot CSV is our is
that you know base case um tidy format
of our Evo data frame right below dia
right it's it's the classic
I mean IDF or AOL CSV is our base case
tidy format but what we're mostly going
to be using is our LOD F which is really
the simplified version to actually
create our low scores where it just has
a match ID a date afire opponent in the
outcome and their weight class
okay so first what we're gonna do is
what's interesting about um shiny
dashboard is it actually doesn't use the
same fluid pages it uh it uses instead
just a dashboard dashboard page so this
is our actual UI and then we can add in
our dashboard header we have a dashboard
sidebar a dashboard body okay and that's
it so it looks a little confusing
um confusing but it's not too bad
because the majority of stuff is
actually gonna go into our dashboard
body so pro dashboard header we're gonna
say our title is equal to
UFC - or lower dashboard okay and we'll
just run this app save it and what do we
see here we have a base on USC dashboard
okay so one thing that we gotta do is we
gotta start adding some templates you
know we want to start adding some stuff
so what we're first gonna do is actually
add some tabs okay
and right now I think we're gonna do a
two tab dashboard so for the dashboards
dashboards sidebar I'm gonna add a some
I'm gonna use a sidebar menu function
and I'm gonna add some tabs basically
using the menu item so each each sidebar
for the sidebar we have a sidebar menu
and the sidebar menu has a menu item
okay so we're gonna add I think all the
weight class and then we're gonna call
this a weight class tab so this is
basically the title of this um tab and
then we have kind of like an identifier
for the alcohol tab name okay and then
what's cool is we can actually add an
icon so for this boom we're gonna say
icon equals dashboard and they just use
on this one websites
there's one websites uh kind of like
characters so you can just specify
dashboard okay let's see what it does
okay so now we have weight class and you
have this cool little dashboard icon for
free okay so we're gonna add another
menu item and this is gonna be our head
to head our tab name will be a head tab
and then our icon will be a I con LSA
dashboard so when I was originally
planning this dashboard um I thought
it'd be cool to just see okay we can
kind of select a weight class select a
weight class and kind of see the the the
history of the weight class II low-rank
eloah has like the Ehlo distributions we
can see the ego times
yo distributions and maybe like a top
five fighters for that weight class as a
table and then we'll add a little slider
that where you can kind of select the
weight classes okay so it's gonna be a
pretty basic thing there's only gonna be
about I guess two plots one table and
like one filtering so we have that one
thing we gotta realize though is okay so
we have our sidebar menu but we also
need to add in some items in our inner
[Music]
in in our dashboard right so that's
where we go to our dashboard body okay
and this is like the meat and potatoes
of the alcohol dashboard so for the
dashboard body we actually have to add
the tab items okay please we have
multiple tabs and then for each and then
for each tab we have to specify tab item
and then specifically the tab name so we
can specify like okay so in this tab
we're gonna in this tab we're gonna add
the plot so first we're gonna kind of
work on the weight class tab okay and
then now we can start putting in our
plots okay but I'm gonna ask the add
another tab item in this case will be
tab name equals and then it'll be ahead
dad okay so all of our plots so we'll go
into the into these uh these tab items
okay so each each tab item is
essentially that the tab page in the
content so we just say like oh I want to
apply right there app all right here
Yatta Yatta okay so we had that we also
have to start making our plots but first
we can kind of look at our yo DF and we
see that we don't have we don't have our
elos right because what I thought would
be cool is what if we also add not just
filtering for the the weight class but
also filtering for the specifying the K
value of of the actual ego
system okay so what we're gonna have to
do is basically um have a function that
will create our Ehlo data frame with a
given K okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna just kind of like we're
gonna prototype it first so we're first
going to go run winter to fighter and K
equals we're gonna say k equals twenty
first data equals zero D F and for this
we're also gonna arrange it by the
fighter and a date so that way we can
add anything we want to it at the end
okay so we have that we have an object
okay but we need to create this into a
table so as that table or as on a store
table and now we have this thing
okay so there's multiple ways that we
can actually do this one thing that I
would say is we could do a pivot longer
so we say pivot longer contains a B and
then - yada yada but I think I'm going
to do it a classical round first so
first I'm gonna have to see bind the ego
stuff that I want so arranged by loop
two five fire fighter and date if we
actually look at this so Erin prank are
these three okay right so we can look at
this and we can see since here see that
it matches up right it's gonna match up
so we can comfortably see vine whatever
you want okay so in this case we're
going to select the and we're gonna
select the match ID all right so now we
have a match ID for what we want
okay that's great additionally we can
see we can we just have this as our data
frame first okay so we have that so
we'll close our temporary data frame
and then our temporary data frame what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have to
our bind them together but in this case
we have to select you know team a's data
right with the match I do okay so how
we're gonna do that first we can do this
we can say again actually I said let's
here yeah yeah okay
additionally what we need to do is we
need to select the relevant stuff so we
want team de a teamed up B um II load a
and E lo dot B and match ID right teamed
oh hi dad kappa lies these things so
team de a net b o uo dot a you would
that be okay so we have our temp data
frame we got that stuff do you think
about it we're not gonna plot out the
updates or the Prague post we're just
gonna plot out their élow okay so we
don't need that stuff so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do the Select at
and then bars contains and first we're
gonna do the dot a okay so we want bars
containing I'm a and we also want the
match ID all right so that's all we go
got basically well our Ehlo and our
match IDs and we're gonna do a rename a
rename all dot funds equal egos function
x kc our replace x dot a and boom okay
so we'll go back up let's here we have
our match ID and stuff like that okay
we're gonna do the same thing but
instead of
dot B I'm gonna have that okay so once
we do that we also need a our bind it so
are buying Boom Boom Boom
and we have our full data frame okay
additionally what we got to do is left
join our DF but we'll select the let's
see what else what do we need probably
fight we probably want the fighter day
way class and match ID because we know
we need the wake lost and since we're
doing a time series we should we should
also join the date okay so we got that
and we'll say OOP by equals C fighter
and match ID cuz I do fighter is missing
why is it saying fire is missing laj oh
what it was DF saying fighter select
fighter okay
oh it's saying it's team interesting
okay so we'll just rename Fighter equals
eCos team right so now we have our
fighter data frame there we go
then we can do a left join and we have
what we wanted where we have our low we
have our master you ever do a weight
class okay I'm just gonna make sure we
have I'm gonna look at these structures
of its fighter is a character UO is a
number master DS int that's fine date is
a character so we're gonna do is mutate
the date so mutate date equals as day
date okay so now we have our data frame
with a given okay we have all itself
okay and yes this is extremely messy but
luckily we're gonna put this into a
function and we won't have to really
look at it anymore
okay so I'm gonna do that boom so what
we're gonna say we're gonna say create
create a load data function and we give
it a kay right because um we want to
generate this data frame whenever with a
specified Kay okay it's okay and then we
have K equals K all right we can do that
we have it so now we have our function
will actually create our ehlo data so
let's let's just try it you own data and
we'll say 20 and it gives us a K of our
data frame whereas there Ehlo the match
ID the day in the weight class a great
stuff and what's cool is we just kind of
have this in a little small function
okay
and that's basically good so we kind of
did most of the actual logic now what
we're gonna have to do is create some
some charts which is probably the most
fun part about it so
what are we gonna do first let's create
a let's see what else could we do
well how come let's start creating our
filters first right
so with the filters we need to figure
out how to do a weight class and a K so
I think the simplest thing to do is
probably the K okay so let's do it
so for here we have our weight class tab
in our tab item um everything that you
put into a dashboard for shiny tax shiny
dashboard must be a inside of box so
this is what we're gonna do we're gonna
say slider input um because I think
would be a good idea is just kind of
like a slider where the person doesn't
have to like type it in it is kind of
the dirac click and drag right so we
have a slider input our input ID what
equal is equal to let's say all all
inputs will start without V first so V
and let's say K and for this K value
will say it will be for the weight class
tab and the weight class have is one so
be honest for K 1 square 1 okay inner
label is a kk4 eloah our min will be one
hour max will be you know 100 and let's
say our default value will be 20 okay so
now we actually have a a well we have
now a slider and if we look at it we can
just run this and we have a slider we're
can just kind of drag it around and this
will specify that K okay so what else -
what else can do well what we can do now
is we can start making a table right
let's we'll just find the top 5 fighters
for on the K okay so in this tab we'll
go to our box
let's see your box
okay box and we'll say a table output
and this table will be the top five
table great
it seems pretty standard top five table
okay so since we have our table named we
have to actually put an output so output
top five table and what we have to do is
render the table okay mmm yep and then
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
generate our data frame right so we'll
say table of DF and we'll say create a
low data right so create uo data and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
the user specify the K and this so we
have to give it an input so the entire
idea behind our shiny it's just inputs
and outputs right so and it's mostly
just inputs we're mostly specifying the
inputs so for our data we're going to
give it an input and the input is user
specified where it's input ID VK one
where we're saying okay we're gonna
create a table or we're gonna create our
eloah data using the cave of 20 as a
default and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say table DF group by spider
arranged by descending order of fighter
eagle and then what we're gonna do is
slice one on group and then top and
fighter uo n equals five arranged by
Fighter II low and then what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna say select NATO
fighter fighter Evo and then mutate rank
equals row number okay
row number so let's see what that looks
like
okay so you see yeah like I'm not really
testing it I'm just gonna test it out
with using the actual app so I'm gonna
run the app and it says Fighter II lo it
is not found interesting why is it not
found so let's go here what's it called
yellow so it's called yo my bad so what
we'll say is i uo range right you go
Frank boom there we have it we have our
evil it's not sorting correctly so what
we're gonna do is select a range
descending order
boom okay so we have that but 1tsp John
Jones
Anderson Silva Tony personal sorority
let's see if the actual K works okay
goes 20 let's say K equals 66 see it see
how it's changing the EO is changing our
91 Tony Ferguson is now on top we do
like 9 so you can see it's changing it's
reacting it's actually pretty fast
um the e load package is pretty fast
with the creating it so I was
comfortable just always creating the new
dataset if you really wanted to optimize
performance we will just kind of have it
in here and not have it in each
rendering that's fine so we're gonna do
that now well I'm thinking about if we
look here is I kind of want the table to
be kinda like over here and I want these
[Music]
functions to be kind of right here so
then so then I can see these two main
plots where I want to see a time series
plot and a distribution pot right over
there where I can just filter out K work
and change the K and also I could
project into weight class
right because we want it to be by weight
class so that's what we're gonna do
so first let's make a oh let's make
let's make the time series plot let's
make the time series plot so I'm just
going to put this on top right
it's a box plot output and we'll say a
kilo time serie time time time series um
so what do we have to do we gotta make
another output so output uh UO time Siri
time series right uooo uooo time series
and that render a plot and we'll say Evo
time series DF create a load data input
V k10 time series DF and then we'll say
GD pump actually mmm you know what I'm
what I'm gonna do actually is I'm gonna
include the top five fighters so I'm
gonna say top five fighters five top
five top five fighters what we're gonna
do is we're just gonna do this I'm gonna
paste this thing in group by top and and
then what we're gonna do actually is
we're going to say select name sucked
fighter right because that's that's what
we want we'll get it oh let's do column
names fighter right because we want the
fighter okay then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna use our ello time series DF
I will say let's just do a simple GG
plot so GG pot data equals zero time
series DF AAS x equals date y equals
zero
Plus giome well I will do genome point
plus GM point again but in this case
we're actually I say a data equals zero
time series DF do you filter and we'll
say the fighter is in our top five
fighters tab our data frame right and
then what we'll say is a es x equals
date y equals I'm evil and color equals
fighter all right let's see what let's
see what happens okay so right here we
have it and you can see these are all
the fighters and we can see kind of like
the name the colors of the top five
fires and where they were at okay I'm
gonna add just one more thing so a
themed legend dot position equals top so
that looks pretty good
you know let's here so we have that we
can kind of change it alright see how
the fires change okay great we have that
and now um let's do a fighter
distribution okay so let's say let's do
right here um box plot output fighter
also eloah just you oldest alright okay
put it down here output you go just
render plot okay you go dis create geo
Kadem oh man
boom and then this is gonna be a simple
one so we'll just say ggplot you data
equals yo just
aes x equals y lo plus Q and we'll do
what we'll do a histogram first right
that makes sense
run it yeah easy PC you can see it icon
on mm-hmm yeah cool cool looks really
good
okay I kind of like the slider I flip to
the right so I'm gonna put this thing
above below it or whatever box too and
then what we're gonna do is rock sure
you know we're gonna actually add
another one too
so in this case we want to add a weight
class so there's no there's a few ways
we can do this okay so we could just do
a what does it call it it's a select
input thing or we could do a you render
UI so that way our select input can be
reactive to other filtering and that's
what we're gonna do so we're gonna do
render actually a UI output and once a
weight class Oh we'll say V weight class
1 V weight class 1 and what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna put all of our filter
options or filtering options right here
okay so output V weight class 1 render
UI okay so now I'm gonna have to go okay
cool looks good I'll do I'll do the
actually I'll do the I'll do the
cleaning later ok so render you live so
what we're gonna do is select input and
then our input I input ID equals
actually mmm yeah okay I kind of messed
this up Sophie wait lost one we'll just
say um wait class selector one weight
class selector one okay so I'm gonna put
that where's that add weight class
selector why so so though this is the UI
output is in the name of the actual
selector object and then V weight cost
one is the actual input variable it's a
little confusing but it's not too bad
you just kind of get it kept get used to
it
so label equals weight class and then we
get a choices thing choice of Troy Oh
choices and in this case we actually
don't need to make this really a
reactive thing however I think it's a
good practice to do it so we'll just say
weight class 1 DF DF Oh create kilo data
input V K one weight class one I spelled
DF in this case our choices need to be
like the weight classes so we're gonna
say select weight class just thing and
we'll just say range my weight class
just so it'll put it out and uh you know
in a distinctive order
all right so choices equals this pretty
simple let's look at it so we're
basically a list of weight classes and
then that's what we have for available
and we have you see that we have our
available things I kinda don't like how
it drips off like that but maybe I can
put this above it and it'll it'll fix a
little bit so we're gonna do that yeah
let's do that
that
okay cool so we have this you know not
great but if we notice something it's
not really filtering anything right
because that we got because we actually
have to put this into it now okay so we
have to remember our weight loss is an
input ID weight class so we're gonna do
that we're gonna say create crate kilo
data and this case we're just a filter
weight class equals input input boom
whew a class one right here top five
fighters filter weight claw clasp equals
input boom type that in yo distribution
we'll say yo just and we'll just put
here filter weight class equals input
boom let's see what it does oh sure I
think I for at the table there we go
so what do you see it's a little bit
different right hope it's a little
different always here
I think the this one's old is not right
yeah it's a firefighters not right so I
would say filter weight class equals
input boom that way we don't have to
deal with that okay cuz I'm just
changing source data I think most of the
full filtering I'll please put in to
that that central area okay this looks
much better you can see how that it's a
less dense right because we're in
bantamweight we can go to catch way cuz
I I actually was guten catch wait catch
way is kind of like a made-up way class
where people kind of decide they wait
arbitrarily that suits both fires so
that's why that there's not a lot okay
so and then we can do middle way middle
way distribution we also changed K see
how the K ranges change right pretty
cool so yeah that's like there's some
pretty good stuff right here um I think
one thing that I might do is man I kind
of want to at use the cable package and
kind of tweak this table but I really
don't know it very well
um so I'm gonna let you guys deal with
that okay so now what we're gonna do is
the the head to head and I think I
talked about this last week
where I was saying I go it'd be cool if
you could select like you know a fighter
fighter right fighter right here fighter
right there and then have their
probabilities out put it right there
right that makes that makes a lot of
sense
um and we could filter it by weight
class right so what we're kind of doing
is kind of a little a little complicated
right um if you think about it it's a
simple idea right weight class we have a
way cost then the fire is available and
the fighter - and the fighter filters
should only be in that weight class and
when we choose a fighter in one tab the
other fighter or the opponent tab can't
contain that fighter right so what we're
going to do is some filtering of the
filtering where each each actual slicer
filter has to affect each other okay and
that's actually not too hard well we're
actually going to do is we're gonna have
to create a what is it called a UI
output basically a UI output its first
that's what we're gonna do so what we're
gonna say is uh let's see here how
should we do is let's just do UI OC Fox
UI output actually scratch that we're
gonna put this into a row so we know
it'll be in in one single row so that
way the opponent and the fire will be
sitting on same row and we know we'll be
in the same row okay so UI output and
we'll say fighter one selector and then
box UI output opponent selector I don't
know why it's a fighter one we don't
need we'll only need to do a fighter
selector opponent selector okay so we
have those two things let's see if it
actually does anything it shouldn't do
anything to be honest yeah we got that
then head ahead nothing here but we have
something starting cool mmm
so I'm gonna put these guys down
okay oh I'm just gonna you know okay so
now what we're gonna do is output
fighter so op fighter selector render
table a render render UI oh no no yeah
render UI okay okay so our first we're
gonna assume everyone's in choose a
fighter first okay so that'll be fine
hmm actually now I think about it now
we'll just do it we'll do it so our
select we're gonna do a select input
which will be when you know those like
drop pulldown tabs select input so input
input ID equals v5o fighter to fighter
to fighter V fighter fighter - because
it's on a second tab I don't think we
actually used of the other one actually
would say V fighter that'll be fine
and then our our label is fighter and
her choices is this alright so we're
gonna say oh is it create the create
create yo-yo data
I'm spider so we'll say oops fighter you
a fighter selector yeah
create you a data input V K and then
this in this case where I shouldn't use
a second one because we have to bring in
another one so that's why I was kind of
getting a little um bogged into
something so what's a fluid row what's
what's just which is create let's create
the at this the this sort of the V was
it the slider this fire input
Jesus it's a slider input box slider
input was it wait no it's a solder input
vk2 label label equals K poor evil min
equals 1 max equals 100 value equals 20
I think we probably could just replica
this thing in but I'm not sure and I
honestly I don't really feel like
messing it up
right so we got that V equals k2 right
and then fighter selector DF select
spider just stanked arranged by fire
fighter cool so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna copy this and paste that guy
in call it a day fire selector DF choice
teachers for fire selector d ok let's
run this and see what it does seeing
some errors for some reason oh no we got
it okay so we have this right one thing
that we also have to add we also have to
add is the the weight class selector so
we'll just do that we know that the
weight class selector is gonna be on top
of the slider input so box a UI output
weight class selector oops
weight class selector - okay to be
honest I don't think we yeah we don't
really need to do this for the weight
classes it can just be distinct but
we're just gonna keep it just in case we
want to do anything crazy so I'm gonna
do this do that weight selector to vo
Kincaid - 2 & 5 okay so we got make sure
it's that dope so now what we're gonna
do is we're not say select 5 filter wait
wait point class equals input input
weight class - boom okay let's do it
let's see what's going on Aaron Phillips
does that make any sense
let's do I think the best ways to
women's catch weight those are all
female names it seems like it's working
it's really good
ok so we have our fighter selector right
here but now we need to do the opponent
selector okay um and the opponent's
object has not been made yet okay yeah
yeah let's do the opponent selector so
output opponent selector render render
UI so what's great why we did the actual
render UI instead of just these select
inputs is now that we have ease in the
actual server functions they can
actually now filter each other with the
date with the data sets what does this
mean it means what we can do is we do
this
I mean it's copy and paste this thing
and it's the same thing however well
we're also going to add as and and
fighter it's not does not equal the [ __ ]
input V fighter input V fighter and
that'll choose a fighter that is not
available so like if if the the fighter
is selected then it won't be available
in the data set that's it's producing
for the choices okay so let's run this
and see if it's working okay argument is
of length of 0 what's going on here
firefighter input data what's going on
here weight class and fighter does not
equal to fighter what's going on in put
me fighter let's see after you double
hands I'm just gonna put this in the
other filter whatever not the most
efficient but but we don't work here how
much input the fighter
let's see that runs arguments only zero
what's going on here oh that's why oops
I forgot there do the select input
select input input V opponent opponent
and will it will say opponent selector
do you have okay that's right because
what is saying is like oh you're not
returning an actual object that we're
expecting you to do boom so we have that
if I do why is this thing not in the
thingy it should be next to each other
we might have to do something but more
about that later so let's let's first
make sure it's working so bantamweight
looks as Davis is Alexis Davis open up
open or available for that one she is
not cool so we have these fighter
selectors done we have our we have our
fighter and opponent selectors done
okay I'm gonna copy and paste this in
there convince these guys okay sweet now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
some tweaking I'm not sure why this is
doing this right now hmm
Boudreaux not sure well so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do another fluid
row and in this case what we're gonna do
is we're gonna add now cards okay but we
need to do is what's cool about shiny
dashboard when we do a shiny - shiny
dashboard a shiny dashboard comes with
some cool cards which are really helpful
for uh for dashboards so let me see here
appearance let's see here it's sorry
that's your yeah so they have these
little wait where is it they have these
things little info boxes and these are
cognized a little summary things that we
can add on to it which can kind of show
out like Oh like whoever like Henry so
kudos probability right there you know
so it seems like a pretty easy way to do
it okay so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna say box box actually we'll
we'll put this underneath it actually
will say ruin row box value whoa box
value box output yep and then box value
output back point value bucks
geez I'm extremely I don't know why but
this diet sodas make me burp a little
bit okay so almost a fighter card and
we'll say
opponent card okay so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna start adding to these
cards so we'll say output fighter card
was it a render value box why is it
value box what is it what's here oh my
value box oh it's yeah render render
render value box okay okay so what we're
gonna do now is we're going to say we're
going to use our create evil data so
let's say fighter card yeah input V k2
and then we'll what kind of copy this
guy and we'll say what's it opponent
opponent card and that's a 1/10 card DF
and then for this will say oh actually
we don't you need ya know we we have to
do that we don't have to do this so we
have to do is since we're going to try
to predict the probabilities of it we're
gonna have to create an actual élow
object okay so this is yellow dot run
run run and say winner - fire + opponent
k equals input VK - data equals 0 DF
call us below because we have to create
probabilities we have to create an eel o
object so that way we just have to
specify the K value and finally we we
can do this so we can do the was it
fighter
prob equals and we say data frame data
frame fighter equals in input was it V
fighter
opponent equals input the opponent okay
know what we're gonna do is predict and
whilst predict and we'll give it the
evil object and do that's and the
prediction and what was due so we're
gonna do that we're gonna do that in
this case since we want the the
opponent's prob we need to switch
fighter an opponent around
okay so boom and then go right cuz
they're just wishing around and we'll
get the same probability and we can
always do a sanity check okay so now
that we have the prob they're probably
the fighter probabilities we can do a
value card was it so value box and then
value equals pay will just say paste
fighter
oops fighter prom and then we'll say was
it oh yeah the % and yeah um yeah
that'll be their value
oh well yet this as I said sappy goes
boom boom and we'll say uh sub title
equals paste and then we'll say input V
fighter I got to make sure his input V
fighter fire selector where is it
fighter yeah input V fire yep okay so
input is gonna be see we're say okay
input is the fighters name and we're
gonna say fighter probability set P go
boom and want to say since the fighter
will always be blue we say the fire card
will be blue and then one thing that was
I was looking up is we can you do the
hand rock thing and that all that I'll
basically do what we're what we wanted
to do okay so let's do the same thing
opponent prob so opponent problem input
V opponent color will be Brett cool so
we have these things let's see if it
works
dope this works obviously fighter sweet
so we have these things what we note is
ok we need to change this into a kinda
have to round this right we got a
multiply it by 100 and then round and in
this case I want just like 51 no
decimals no frills so that's what we're
gonna do let's say 100 times and we'll
say round round this value to 0 decimal
places and we'll do this same thing to
this we're on this to zero decimal
places cool
salt round wrong around boom-boom we got
that
so we have our probabilities blue and
red corner
our opponents Aaron films we can also
change the the people so we can choose
like oh we wanna will get women's
bantamweight we're gonna look at let's
see manda Nunez versus say let's see
where's Irene aldana stuff like that we
also changed the K and Cl it's sense
that how the sensitivity changes it one
thing I gotta do is I want to fix this
thing and then we'll just call it a day
so I'm gonna fix it and say and let's
find out what's going on here I'm
honestly not sure why this is doing this
for the fights interesting
oh there you go okay okay so we're gonna
hit that and we finally have it finally
have it so yeah if this is a short tyre
Tuesday video but we finished the
dashboard and with [ __ ] with a shiny
dashboard and it's pretty quick when we
took an hour-and yeah let's do a
simulation so let's see women's what
women's bantamweight men in new Nunez
and let's say uh let's see if it's
[ __ ] Spencer here first Hall hall at
home 60% probability for probability
pretty cool stuff we can also see how we
can see the distributions of these guys
and kind of show the change in yo what
change in evil scores and home with the
changing K so yeah I'll see guys next
weekend tell you on